the programmer an offshoot of the great
ape family closely related to chimps and
gorillas distinguished by its minimal
bipedal movement and ability to stare at
a computer screen for the majority of
its lifetime there's an estimated 30
million specimens alive in the world
today normal humans use stereotypes to
help understand and generalize this
unusual variant which experts estimate
are about 99 accurate about 12 of the
time in today's video we'll take a look
at 10 different programmer stereotypes
to find out which one you fall into
first up we have the gear head this
variant owns the bleeding edge version
of everything like the latest m1 mac a
big ass curved monitor mechanical
keyboard tesla in the garage ai
generated synthetic meat in the fridge
and a smart lock on the house to keep it
all safe when programming he goes
wherever the hype train takes him in 96
it was java in o6 it was jquery in 2016
it was graphql and in 2026 he'll be
first in line at neural link to get a
chip that can help him write blazingly
fast code it doesn't matter what the
tech does if it's trendy it belongs in
the stack this stereotype may be true
sometimes but programming can actually
push many people in the opposite
direction the guy who works in tech but
hates text stereotype knows exactly how
unreliable and dangerous code can be
like that the rac25 incident where a
little software bug accidentally killed
some people by giving them a massive
overdose of radiation this guy would
never buy a car that can be remotely
summoned back to elon when you stop
paying the bill and he would definitely
never put a smart lock on his house
because the nsa probably has backdoor
access or at the very least there's an
undiscovered exploit in its code if you
broke into his farmhouse you'd find a
single monitor linux machine a flip
phone some gold bullion and a shotgun
barrel pointed in your face
the most stereotypical programmer though
has to be the introvert he's a savant
who still sleeps in a car bed and his
vision of the ideal lifestyle is what
the rest of society calls quarantine
he's super good at math and can actually
program stuff without using google and
stack overflow but couldn't hold a
conversation to save his life extroverts
like jobs use these nerds like woz to
get super rich this stereotype used to
be 100 true back when programming was
hard like pre-1990s but as programming
has become more mainstream it's led to a
new paradigm the programmer this guy got
a computer science degree while mostly
partying with his frat in college
his name is usually chad and he has more
mating opportunities than the introvert
but it comes at a cost of reduced code
quality which he refuses to test because
test driven development is for losers
nah bro however he has better
communication skills than the introverts
which is annoying because i wish this
guy would stop talking to me eventually
he evolves into your manager where he
can torment you with code reviews and
team building exercises now so far in
this video i've been using a lot of
masculine pronouns that's because 95 of
my audience is male which is actually
pretty close to the real world
distribution today what you may not
realize though is that back in the day
women used to dominate the programming
space kathleen booth created the first
assembly language grace hopper created
the first compiler and margaret hamilton
led the team who wrote the code for the
apollo moonlander code that was so
flawless and perfectly executed that
some people think it's proof we didn't
actually go to the moon that was the
apex of code quality since that time
everything's gone downhill the next
specimen we'll look at is the influencer
or code fluencer his natural habitat is
not a code editor but rather a social
media platform most commonly twitter
after figuring out how to print hello
world in php he immediately rose to the
top of the dominance hierarchy in his
own mind now he makes the world a better
place by regurgitating code tips and hot
takes all day long and he just landed a
better paying job than you because he
mastered the art of virtue signaling and
that's what we call a good culture fit
another popular stereotype is the hacker
this guy's able to open up a terminal
connect to some remote mainframe and
break all of its security protocols one
by one with awesome fancy animations
between each step this stereotype is
what most people think programmers do
but is 100 manufactured by hollywood
real hacking is extremely tedious and
boring and is done primarily by the
people who have all the guns now a
stereotype that is actually real is the
10x developer this guy is an extremely
rare unicorn that can do the work of 10
other developers combined some say
they're a myth but i've seen developers
first hand who write code like durant
plays basketball or kasparov plays chess
there are people out there with a
natural problem-solving ability that
just goes far beyond the rest of the
population you'll know a 10x developer
when you see one because you'll feel
very incompetent and also very jealous
now i think the ideal stereotype for
most of us to fall into is the lazy
programmer to the outside world it
doesn't look like this guy does much he
sits at a computer all day hitting the
keyboard and if you glance at a screen
it looks like he's just copying and
pasting things from the internet what
he's actually doing though is building a
million dollar side hustle so he can
retire in his 30s he also has a remote
job with a 400k salary but he eats ramen
for dinner while sharing a crappy
apartment with four other dudes his
wardrobe is 50 swag from tech
conferences and 50 thinks his mom bought
him he leverages code to work smarter
and not harder now on the other end of
the spectrum we have the old jaded guy
he has long silver hair and a big white
beard he only codes in c not c plus plus
and definitely not any of the hipster
garbage that you're using in fact he
probably wrote the compiler for the
silly toy language that you're trying to
learn his depth of knowledge transcends
the normal apes idea of reality when he
discovered through psychedelics that
we're all just one entity that found a
hack in the universe to experience
itself in parallel with primate bodies
and computers are the tool that will
ultimately make us one again and that
concludes our presentation on programmer
stereotypes let me know which one you
fall into in the comments below thanks
for watching and i will see you in the
next one